The Joe Rogan Experience yeah I like it
I'm really really really really digging
I'm glad you're doing it I got I gotta
do it Joe I've been wanting to do it for
so long I just I don't you know and it's
so crazy too because I thought that my
hook would be
so my trainer basically told me I'm
southpaw
I I thought I was a right-handed boxer
he's like no your left-handed box I was
like you do right with your left hand
right with my left hand you run with
your life I do everything with my left
hand but fight with your left hand
forward your right hand forward my right
hand forward okay so you fight South
Paul yes yes so
I thought
I thought that my right hand was the
strongest
that's what I thought but my left hand
is the strongest but I got a killer
right hook though too but my left hook
sucks but it's all in my in my balance
he said but your power is your too
right you're straight left yeah yeah so
because I was like no no no no no I was
like my power
is is my right hand he said no it's your
left hand so we got in a fight so he was
like what he was he so he came charging
at me and as he was charging at me I did
this to him he was like you stop Paul if
you would have did this then you would
have been right because you were trying
to set him up for a big left hand right
I stopped him with that he said that is
your jab hand that's how I know your
power coming coming from you we know a
lot of Fighters uh they would fight
Southpaw even though they were
right-handed that was Oscar De La Hoya
yeah he's right-handed but he fights
Southpaw so his strong hand will be
forward okay okay yeah there's different
schools of thought on that yeah like
Emmanuel Stewart did that with a lot of
people he took guys that were uh natural
right-handed and he put him in a
southpaw stance because if you're also
if you're learning from a southpaw
stance you have an advantage that most
people fight Orthodox so when you're
fighting it gives people a very when you
fight someone who's a southpaw it's
confusing when you're boxing because
everything's backwards yeah so if you're
not used to it like in the early days of
boxing but then the best guys are guys
like Terence Crawford who could just
switch or boots Ennis who just switch
they just switch they can fight you
Southpaw they could fight you Orthodox
you're like oh Jesus like you don't know
where the [__] punches are coming from
they're coming from everywhere yeah
that's why you gotta learn how to stick
and move get out of it back in the day
that was really rare like Marvin Hagler
was the great at that he was he was like
the most famous who was it Marvin Marvin
Hagler Marvelous Marvin Hagler yeah he
was the middleweight champion he knocked
out Tommy Hearns and I mean Hagler in
his time was a destroyer and Hagley
would fight so he would switch it up all
the time he fight Orthodox he'd fight
Southpaw he can go back and forth he
would throw a punch and switch stances
it was a totally it was very rare in
hagler's day that an elite world
champion would switch stances so
effortlessly but now you got like
Terence Crawford does it like I said
boots Ennis does it I don't I don't I
ain't gonna say I can't do it I'm saying
I never have but I might it's a good
thing to learn if you can learn how to
do things from your left side it
actually shows you how to do things
better from your right side weirdly
enough it actually helps you I'm still
learning how to write with my right hand
I can't can't even hold this yeah
I broke my arm once and I had to do that
I had to learn how to write and draw
with my left hand I mean I think I can
but it's gonna be it's awful you can
it's but you have to teach your Hannah
to do it which is so interesting because
you would think if your left hand does
it so well your right hand would just
you would just tell your right hand to
do it yeah but my left hand is stupid it
just doesn't listen good my right hand
is like exactly I kind of like being
left-handed though it's like
you know crazily when I was growing up I
got bullied for being left-handed a lot
of people do you know it's like I was
the weird one they used to think it was
satanic yeah it's just like
they would tell left-handed people to
not use their left hand back in the day
that but when I was in school they
didn't do that to me but the kids would
bully me for being left-handed for being
out yes that's so stupid I am for having
duck feet do you know I look goofy
because I hate boxing sometimes and
watching myself because I'm so goofy my
feet are duck feet so nice play out yes
and I can't get up you know I'm trying
to get them to stay straight but when I
see you know I know what happened I
always had duck feet but I look so goofy
when I'm boxing because I hurt my niece
playing soccer when I was in college I
was I don't know how to play soccer but
I was you know
playing and I went to do a Power kick
and this person blocked me so my body
went one way and my leg went the other
way I messed my knee up so
I just look goofy when I'm boxing but
that I might use that as a as an
advantage think about like look at this
goofy-footed [__] then I didn't let
I'll whack somebody
but I can do it and I love it so you're
really thinking about fighting it seems
like you're you've got a plan in your
head because you're saying you're like
painting scenarios where people
underestimate you and you [__] them up
like so in my mind you're thinking about
this I've been thinking about it for a
long time really okay have one please
don't have a lot don't get don't get
your head I really want to do celebrity
boxing who would you want to fight ah I
don't know we'll call somebody out I
probably will
smile at my dog Sam J what's up [__]
let's fight uh do you uh think that like
how much time would you need to prepare
for something like that
um a month that's it really I'm telling
you I I'll be out here you doing a lot
how often do you uh if I could do if I
can just like box
six days a week
for
a month 24 days you know you ready to
[__] somebody up hell yeah
I'm [__] right I believe you know
short fingernails no no need to I would
like to fight my peers the people that I
love now really now I could I don't know
why you want to hurt him just because
it's fun which is you know just like
messing around like kids you know just
messing around with my partners and [__]
but I do be thinking about starting beef
with people just to like just to [__]
them up yeah really yeah don't do that
yeah especially now that you're on TV
look I see a man look I'll be watching
Clarissa Fields I'm like that's a big
fluorescent Shield what I said Clarissa
fields
so Mikey Davey making fun of me because
I get everybody name for us Joey Diaz's
move this is an entire videos of him
saying people's names and I said with
confidence too of course yeah he does
too he calls uh Stipe mioces steel pick
oh yeah he calls him steel pick he
called uh khabib nurmagomanoff he used
to call him yeah the [__] calabib
gets a hold of you yeah the color Bean
the color bib yeah yeah I I do have a
name problem I'm gonna get it together
but that's a big cheap big like that
that her I wouldn't want to fight her
you ever heard of Ann Wolfe oh is that
uh like she ain't she old now yes yeah
wolf uh she used to be uh a trainer she
was training people after she fought and
um what's his name
James Kirk the guy he fought Canelo yeah
yeah she's a she's a cycle yeah she had
the most vicious one part right here
right there one of the most vicious one
punch KO in women's boxing look at that
and she did a little dance after us
that was I mean they had talked to gang
[__] before that fight and unfortunately
she talks to getting [__] to the wrong
lady because you know Ann Wolfe had like
legit one punch KO power
James Kirkland that's who it was and who
uh eventually went on to fight Canelo
but watch this look at them arms oh my
God but it's also the skill she's
setting up this overhand right
looking at it then eyes mm-hmm
measure measure and then she comes
forward too predictably boom slip oh my
goodness knockout I mean it's like one
of the greatest one punch Kos of all
time
phenomenal I mean that's a
an amazing punch look how jacked she was
too but that's one thing I don't want to
get too jacked because my problem is I I
start doing too too much arm work I'll
get jacked yeah yeah jacked heart Jay
that's why I keep my hair because if I
cut it all off I'ma look like a man
I was like I don't want to be I don't
want to look because I I had to chill
out for a second because I don't want to
get that jacked I still want to be a
little cute